15h30 bruno le maire arrive chez general
electric ou des centaines de salariés
l'attendent présente également les gilet
jaune qu'il accueille sous les huées
pendant ce temps dans le hall les élus
de la région et du département patientes
viennent ensuite les salutations
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances s'est d'abord entretenu avec
eux et les dirigeants de geely puis dans
un second temps avec les représentants
syndicaux qui espèrent beaucoup de cette
visite
le déplacement du ministre s'est
terminée par une conférence de presse
il a alors annoncé la mise en place d'un
comité de suivi du pse évoqué
l'importance de réindustrialiser le site
de belfort
reste maintenant à connaître la réaction
des syndicats et des salariés